fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun
salut c'est le secret aujourd'hui on va
tester un nouveau smartphone de chiens
ont mis un des smartphones d'entrée
diane c'est leur ennemi note 5
un smartphone qui était dispo à moins de
250 euros pour lui trouver là à moins
200 euros
est-ce que ce raid minaude saint qui est
intéressant est ce que ça vaut le coup
de se le procurer
oui non je sais que c'est au mitard il
n'y a pas très longtemps en france avec
des produits hyper fort avant pour les
avoir il fallait passer par des
importateurs maintenant vous pouvez
acheter directement auprès de charles vi
et chez plein d'autres revendeurs donc
si vous intéresse vous aimez les liens
des tarifs très intéressants comme adam
description on va tout de suite sans
plus attendre l'ouvrir pour qui au final
serait ni lot 5 qui est intéressant oui
ou non on y va
[Musique]
voici la bête raid minutes 5 alors ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va déjà dans
un premier temps enlevé le mister
regarder fils intéressant up cause des
amis hop ça ça dégage la boîte je la
trouve pas mal c'est vraiment un
standard chez shiomi pour trouver cette
teinte
ici le nom du modèle qui est affichée
tout simplement vous le retrouvez
également notre côté on les blessures
sur une globale vers sean o dont vous
avez quelques spécifications techniques
mais c'est vrai que la boîte est quand
même relativement sobre alors maintenant
couvrons pour voir comment ça se
présente
à l'intérieur voilà je relâche tout
c'est assez sommaire simple efficace
vous avez ici hop une petite partie dans
laquelle vit retrouver je pense une
coque transparente qui est situé juste
là on va tout à l'heure quel rendu elle
a directement sur le smartphone vous
avez ici la bête
or je le récupère c'est vraiment simple
comme emballage en pointe ou simple
efficace a permis au ch et omis de
sortir des téléphones pas trop cher je
pense avec des emballages simple et
efficace au raid minott cinq épreuves
dual camera vous avez eu mon accent
comme extraordinaire 13 mégapixels sur
la caméra avant qualcomm snapdragon 636
14 nanomètres octas core processor bon
tout ça on va regarder teurs un petit
peu plus tout en détail rennes minutes 5
je suppose que c'est une petite fiche
explicative
vous avez quelques informations
notamment au niveau de la carte sim vous
pouvez avoir soin de cartes sim soit une
carte sim et une carte micro sd vous
avez quelques petites informations les
bandes les fréquences le wifi voilà pas
mal de petites choses comme ça à
l'intérieur vous avez ici up votre
adaptateur usb micro usb qui est ici ici
de quoi ou un compartiment pour assurer
votre carte sim est ici votre bloc pour
le charger voilà l'écran durée nuit note
5 au dos c'est pareil on enlève et on a
smartphone tenue c'est pas un design
révolutionnaire vous avez des petits
bords arrondis ici sur les côtés à
l'avant votre caméra différents capteurs
haut parleurs une grande bande en haut
une grande bande en bas sur les côtés
ici un bouton de volume un bouton pour
l'allumer de l'autre côté votre tiroir
pour votre carte sim ou
micro sd en bas un port jack du micro
usb et un haut-parleur ici et à
l'arrière vous avez votre double module
photo à la verticale flash au milieu le
capteur d'empreintes digitales
positionner ici et la marque ici et la
certification européenne
la coque quand elle vient se positionner
alors c'est pas une des causes les plus
protectrices que vous pouvez trouver sur
le marché
néanmoins elle n'est pas vilaine salle
protège quand même c'est vrai que bon
par rapport à ce que j'ai pu voir
ailleurs ça va c'est pas moche ça fait
la sphère petite vibration allumage m
ie9 d'un point de vue éthique c'est un
produit que je trouve quand même bien
réussi 5.99 pousse ses duels cdi ps un
écran 18 9e avec une résolution de 2160
par 1080 pixels
la densité de pixels cdu 403 ppp l'écran
occupe 77% de la face avant
forcément vous avez un bord en eau et en
voir en bas ici pas dans coche mais on
est sur un smartphone qui est pas cher
donc qu'on va pas lui demander la lune
côté performances vous avez instinct
dragon 636 octas core cadencé à 1,86
gars n 4 gigas de ram à 64 giga de
stockage la plus graphique c'est une
qualcomm adreno à 509 ça marche plutôt
bien
ça fonctionne on va pas lui demander la
lune on va pas chercher à voir des
choses qui vont extrêmement vite c'est
plutôt efficace
l' os et android 8.0 est une surcouche m
89.5 vous êtes des applications qui sont
dédiés shiomi vous avez ici le forum
chaumié toutes les informations sur la
mare vous allez avoir une télécommande
ça c'est pas mal lorsque voulais piloter
une telle en infrarouge et puis
différents objets vous avez également
les vidéos me de ce côté là un nettoyeur
pour optimiser votre machine ça c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal pour en
nettoyer pour vider un peu la mémoire ça
c'est quand même relativement
intéressant ça me permet d'optimiser
quand même pas mal la machine
gestionnaire de fichiers directement ici
votre agenda
voilà donc ya pas mal pas mal de petites
choses vous retrouvez aussi des outils
mis drop pour envoyer des fichiers c'est
comme une drogue boxe en réalité votre
boussole télécharger horloge métro tram
on va tous des choses qui sont quand
même relativement classique qui change
là dessus c'est un peu l'interface qui
est propre à shlomi on aime ou on n'aime
pas en attendant ça marche c'est pas mal
côté autonomie vous avez une batterie de
4000 millions perreur donc franchement
ce une batterie quand même assez énorme
pouvoir encaisser votre utilisation
journalière même si vous êtes gourmand
sur des petits jeux parce que c'est fun
bête de compet si vous
jouer si vous allez beaucoup sur
internet sur les réseaux sociaux si vous
utilisez vraiment votre machine à fond
pour partager des vidéos filmées faire
des photos tout ce que vous voulez elle
va encaisser sur une journée sans aucun
problème ça c'est vraiment un des gros
points positifs de ce smartphone autre
point intéressant vous avez dû vous tous
5.0 points négatifs pas de nfc pour les
paiements dématérialisés
vous avez un port jack et allez savoir
que moi j'aime le jack pour avoir mon
petit casque est directement branchée
dessus un haut parleur mono on va partir
dans quelques instants
une recherche en micro usb pas d'usb tic
c'est pour des questions j'imagine de
coupoles du design il n'est pas du tout
révolutionnaire ce type d'écran on
connaît ce format on le connaît il est
assez grand
ça c'est assez intéressant effectivement
on peut profiter d'un écran quasiment 2
6 pouces le dos et pas mal vous avez un
côté métal un peu matt entre le mat et
le brillant
c'est très pratique on a accès très
facilement capteur d'empreintes
digitales pour déverrouiller son
smartphone il est réactif 1 2 3
j'appuie hawk ça marche ça déverrouille
très rapidement c'est vraiment bien je
vous dis après voilà le design est sympa
les bords sont arrondis l'écran aussi
vous avez des bords arrondis
lorsque vous regardez les vidéos vous
avez des petites bandes noires sur le
côté il vous suffit de zoomer pour
agrandir vous allez forcément rogner un
peu sur le haut et sur le bas mais bon
c'est efficace l'écran est plutôt pas
mal aussi dans ce sens là côté photo
vidéo vous avez ici un double capteur 12
mégapixels akin ouverture de f
1.9 et 5 mégapixels avec l'ouverture de
f 2.0
le double objectif va vous servir pour
les faits évoqués pour avoir un flou en
arrière plan à l'avant vous avez une
caméra de 13 mégapixels dans cette fille
offert quelques souvenirs
vous allez pouvoir filmer en full hd
1920 par 1080
vous avez un mode photo un mode portrait
mode carré mode panorama mode manuel
pour régler vos photos directement votre
balance des blancs et vos iso vous avez
pas mal de possibilités
vous pouvez faire de la vidéo la vidéo
courte vous avez une gestion du hdr vous
avez également quelques filtres que vous
pouvez à poser directement vos photos
vous pouvez régler pas mal de paramètres
la qualité de l'image
la trame de l'appareil photo m en 16 9e
18 9e ou en cas de pierre alors vous
êtes pas mal pas mal de petites
possibilités anti bandes noires vous
pouvez régler le contraste la saturation
la netteté donc bon c'est quand même pas
mal au niveau de la vidéo vous avez
possibilité d'avoir une stabilisation de
l'image
oui ou non vous allez filmer en full hd
en mille hd ou en standard j'imagine
même pas celui du 480p quelque chose
comme ça
un retardateur capteur d'empreintes
digitales pour déclencher c'est pas ma
lentille benoît la même manière vous
pouvez choisir de filmer en modelant en
mode accéléré au mode normal pour les
vidéos courtes vous avez des petits
filtre également de ce côté là en mode
vidéo cours devraient pouvoir faire des
vidéos de 10 secondes maximum
voilà pour partager sur les réseaux
sociaux why not une fois n'est pas
coutume on va tester ce smartphone en
rade et si l'appareil photo est
intéressant voir le rendu du point de
vue de la photo voir le rendu du point
de vue de la vidéo voir ci fait la faire
oui ou non alors une fois de plus on n'a
pas s'affoler
c'est un smartphone qui tournera autour
des 200 250 euros donc on n'a pas non
plus s'attendre à des merveilles
malgré tout on va les voir si le rendu
est correcte sur la vidéo est sur la
photo on y va tout de suite il fait un
temps magnifique aujourd'hui
alors voyons voir au niveau de la vidéo
lorsque c'est une nuit directement comme
ça est ce que c'est bien
est-ce que c'est pas bien je vais
décrocher les quelques instants on va
regarder ça voir si le rendu est correct
oui ou non
pour l'instant ce que je fume comme ça
je trouve quand même que c'est pas mal
c'est très très honnête par rapport à ce
que je vois à l'écran le poste est bien
d'autofocus marche plutôt bien
la netteté et là elle est au rendez vous
qu'en est il maintenant la caméra de
celle fille de ce que je vois la salle r
quand même pas trop mal
le rendu à rien d'être correct on va les
voir maintenant place au soleil c'est
bien pour vous faire plaisir je m'en
passerai en train de cramer la tête
d'une légère stabilisation c'est pas mal
c'est une stabilisation électronique
paypal stabilisation optique là dessus
mais en attendant ça fait jobs
donc c'est quand même relativement pas
mal verdict pour la photo et pour la
vidéo
je suis franchement agréablement très
agréablement surpris parce que lorsque
vous regardez les photos il ya du vrai
détail j'ai des films et vous un peu
plus cosy qu'un succès le printemps des
romains d'aujourd'hui c'est ces premiers
jours de l'été donc bon été à tous un
bon vin en juin qui bonne fête de la
musique vous la rentrée on sera plus le
21 juin mais bon j'espère que c'est pas
passé pour vous peu importe ses
prestigieux aujourd'hui mais il ya
vraiment du point de détail
voyez
au niveau des feuilles vous voyez
vraiment dû d'état lorsque vous allez
zou met dedans ça c'est vraiment bien
pareil sur la vidéo le rendu est
vraiment correct on né en 1920 par 1080
on n'est pas en 4k uhd mais
fondamentalement je passe sur vous en
ayez besoin
le rendu est vraiment bien et ce par
connaître vraiment que je suis
agréablement surpris par ce smartphone
pour un tarif aux alentours des 250
euros pour le coup pour la photo la
vidéo c'est vraiment top qu'en est il
maintenant de l'audio est ce que le haut
parleur est à la hauteur est ce qu'il
est bien par rapport au reste c'est un
petit peu ce qu'on va regarder leur ont
déjà regardé sur ce que je vienne filmé
à l'instant en extérieur c'est bien pour
les jeunes maintenant pas 60 rames de
tram et la tête on va regarder tout ça
reste à voir si ça c'est pas mal je
trouve que l'audio et bien alors là je
regarde quelque chose que j'ai filmé
directement le smartphone ça marche
plutôt pas mal on va maintenant regarder
directement sur une vidéo sur youtube du
son on va pas dire ça mange bien le haut
parleur qui est la marche bien
bien positionné si vous voulez jouer
vous le tenez vous n'avez pas le bloquer
il ya un gros volume sonore
ça marche bien ce correct on teste
maintenant un petit morceau fort
sympathique de rammstein qui s'appelle
d'ouest
j'écris un peu parce que c'est réparé
dans le casque la qualité pas mal je
m'attendrais quelque chose d'encore plus
fort avoir un peu plus de son c'est pas
tout le plus dingue que j'ai entendu en
volume sonore mais c'est déjà bien et
une fois de plus il faut pas pousser le
son à fond parce que sinon vous allez
finir complètement saoul je le dis je le
répète et je le maintiens c'est très
important de protéger vos oreilles alors
faites pas les sauvages verdict au
niveau de ce smartphone de ce raid
minott 5
je le trouve plutôt bien on va pas se
mentir je trouve que pour le prix c'est
un très bon smartphone mais plutôt un
excellent smartphone j'ai une vraie
bonne surprise au niveau de la photo et
la vidéo
une vraie bonne qualité et à ce prix là
c'est quand même plutôt rare c'est même
plutôt bien avec ça il faut vraiment le
dire
le design il est pas un novateur le
design il est déjà vu des centaines de
fois qu'ils voulaient pas mettre
beaucoup d'argent à des smartphones et
si vous voulez pas d'encoches celui là
c'est vraiment un excellent format avec
un écran quasiment 6 pouces un format
18/9 une bonne résolution
c'est un smartphone qui est bien je
trouve plutôt sympa cette couleur là en
plus je trouve vraiment très jolie
effectivement mais pas d'usb tisser une
fois de plus c'est un produit qui coûte
pas cher vous crois pas non plus lui
demander la lune il ya l'essentiel dans
ce produit l'essentiel c'est la qualité
de l'écran qui est vraiment correct et
surtout un excellent rendu en termes de
photos et vidéos donc si vous voulez un
très bon smartphone nous allons tourner
200 euros un peu plus voire un peu moins
une fois de plus vous aimez lire la
description pour aller jeter un coup
d'oeil c'est vraiment un excellent choix
vous serez pas déçus la surcouche
et bien si vous aimez l'environnement
chez tommy vous serez pas déçus l'audio
est correct le produit est rapide pas
non plus une bête de compet mais pour
moi aux alentours les 200 euros c'est un
excellent choix
dites moi ce que vous en pensez est ce
que vous l'avez déjà essayé ce produit
est ce qui pourrait vous tenter est-ce
que vous avez des produits chimiques
puisque vous trouvez que l'arrivée de
xiaomi en france est un succès alors
shiomi on a beaucoup parlé parce que la
marque vient d'arriver qui a plein de
produits intéressants qu'on va découvrir
qu'on va tester plein de tests qui vont
arriver et puis d'autres surprises dans
les 20 plus il est resté connecté
d'ici là vous invite à marquer tous vos
commentaires questions suggestions on va
bien évidemment vous voulez c'est joli
pouces vous mettez tout ce que vous
et des bijoux tout ce que vous voulez
directement en bas d'ici là soyez sages
portez vous bien et puis je vous
souhaite une très bonne idée parce que
là on est tout de suite le premier jour
de l'été et ça c'est plutôt cool
on a vraiment eu un temps pourri là je
suis très heureux qu'on ait du soleil va
pouvoir bronzer seins mettre de la crème
solaire partout pour éviter de rougir
comme une écrevisse
mais ça c'est cool donc voilà biloum
soyez sages et à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]